Hey everybody, this is Mike from
Orderflows, and in today's video, I'll
be talking about order flow imbalances.
You know, what causes them, how to see
them in the order flow, their
importance, and more importantly, how to
trade them. You know, some trading
strategies around them.
And you know, if you've been liking the
videos I've been putting out, be sure to
like and subscribe to the channel. You
know, so anytime we put a new video out,
you'll be notified in your
notifications, you know, because
sometimes it's a little hard to get
found in the YouTube algo.
So, an order flow imbalance, you know,
order flow is about understanding the
volumes that are being traded on the bid
and the offer. And you know, just really
quick, if you're looking at, you know,
say the market is 25 bid at 26, there's
32 contracts on the bid, 500 on the
offer. Say, you know, 400 lots traded
against this 32, this 400 would be
colored blue color, right? That would
indicate a buy imbalance. If 32
contracts had traded on the bid, 400 on
the offer, that is what you consider an
imbalance. Now, you could determine
what
ratio between the volume traded on the
bid and the volume traded on the offer.
So, for example, if this was only, you
know, we'll call it a smaller volume,
say only 40 contracts traded here,
but 320 contracts traded on the bid, 40
against 320, you'd consider that
a sell imbalance, right? And that would
be colored red on the footprint. Now,
generally, most traders use
about four to one. I know some
traders like to use 350%,
which is a ratio of three to three and a
half to one. I know some guys that like
to use um
1,000%, which is a ratio of 10 to one.
But whatever you decide to use, you
know, stick with it. And you know, form
your analysis. You're not going to be
going during the trading day and
adjusting it. Okay? Pretty much every
order flow footprint software has the
ability to look at imbalances, you know,
show the imbalances on your chart. Now,
me personally, I like to have the
sell imbalances, right? The aggressive
selling into the bid be colored red. I
like the buy imbalances, the volumes
that are traded on the offer because you
have aggressive buyers lifting that
offer, to be colored blue color.
Right? Because you remember, it's sort
of the the universal standard for buying
is
green or blue, blue for buy, red for
sell.
Simple, right? And so, let's take a
look, you know, on the actual footprint.
So, this is a What is it? We got a bond
5-minute chart. Okay? So, you can see
sell imbalances here.
Right? That's the red numbers inside the
footprint. The blue numbers inside of
the footprint, inside of the bar,
are buy imbalances.
And generally, when you have sell
imbalances, you know, you have more
aggressive sellers. Generally speaking,
the market is going to go down. Just as
if you have aggressive buying, right?
The blue numbers inside the bar, the buy
imbalances, the market generally goes
up. But that's not always the case cuz
it's a little bit nuanced, and I'm going
to get into that in a minute. Now,
again,
um you know, on on the software that I
have, I use
400, which is a ratio of four to one.
But again, you could adjust it. Say you
want it to be, you know, two two and a
half to one. So, you just you'd change
the imbalance trigger to 250, which is
250%. And as a result, by lowering the
threshold, so to speak, the the
imbalance trigger,
you're going to have more imbalances
appearing, right? Cuz now, instead of
looking at, you know, a ratio of four to
one, you're looking at um
two and a half to one. So, I'm seeing,
you know, a few more sell imbalances and
a few more
um buy imbalances in these bars because
I've lowered the threshold. If I went to
a very high number, you know, like a 10
to one or a 1,000%,
there's going to be
a lot less, right? Because now, the
threshold is set higher, right? So, if I
set it to 1,000, right? Which is a ratio
of 10 to one, there's going to be a lot
fewer
that are appearing.
Okay? See, it's very few.
So, let's just go back to, you know, the
my my normal
four four to one ratio, you know, 400%
really quick, and sort of go a little
bit more in depth here. So,
again, like I said, generally, when you
have
buy imbalances,
you're going to be looking for them in
green candles, right? Market is moving
up, you're seeing the aggressive buying,
as you see here. You've got zero against
20, zero against 60, two against 29, 34
against 218. Okay, you have four buy
imbalances in this bar. It's a green
candle. This red candle, you've actually
got a stack sell imbalance here. You've
got one imbalance up near the top, 479
against 14. But down here, you got 189
against 29, 136 against 11, 159 against
two. Okay? So, I know that as we're
going into the low, we're seeing
aggressive selling as we took out that
low. You know, sometimes it's a stop
that gets triggered, um you know, and
and or just more sellers coming into the
market. Now, there are going to be
times, you know, I'm sure someone will
comment on here, "Well, Mike said, you
know, when you got buy imbalances, that
means the market's going up. Why you got
buy imbalances on the red candle and the
market went down, you know, order flow
is a scam." Well, no, you got to
understand what is the reason why you
have that buy imbalance or a sell
imbalance. Again, on a red candle down,
normally, you'd expect to see the
aggressive selling,
which leaves, you know, sell imbalances.
But when you have buy imbalances on
these red candles,
right? Now, that's where it gets a
little more nuanced. And what you're
looking at
is, you know, basically, this market,
you know, it hit the low, it's going
sideways, and it's starting to go back
up, right? You can see in here, you got
a green candle. Then you get, you know,
a sell imbalance as you just sort of
make this I don't want to call it a
little swing high, but it's just a
little bit higher than than you've been
trading since 7:30. This is at just
after 8:00.
Aggressive selling coming in, then you
got a buy imbalance here, a buy
imbalance here, right? And this is a red
candle. Mike just said, you just I just
said, right?
Generally, on red candles, you'd be
looking for sell imbalances. Now, when
you have a buy imbalance, what you
actually have coming into the market is
supply.
Okay? So,
because that supply is absorbing
whatever aggressive buying is going on
in there. There's still aggressive
buying, but you have a passive seller up
there, right? A limit order
that
is taking
all the liquidity, or they're providing
liquidity, rather. And you know, they're
absorbing all the aggressive trading
that's coming into the market, right?
They're when the market is 31 bid at
even, you know, they're offered there at
even, and they're just happy to sell it
at even, right? Market drops a little
further down,
at 29, they're happy to sell it
passively
at 29. They're absorbing that aggressive
buying. Once that aggressive buying is
done at double O,
the market drops a little further, you
know, there's still offers there at, you
know, at 31, at 30, at at 29, and
there's still some aggressive buying
coming in.
And
it's absorbing it, right? The now, the
strong selling is kind of
uh petered off, you know, the bar closed
actually here at uh at 28.
Then the next bar opens up, and there's
you can see there's a strong bid there
at 28, and it gets sold, 781. Now, it's
a sell imbalance.
Market keeps going down, another sell
imbalance comes in here, then you got a
stack sell imbalance. Now,
that sort of leads us to, you know, I'll
talk about stack sell imbalances, but
you know, when you're seeing buy
imbalances
on red candles, right? Candles that are
closing lower than where those
um buy imbalances are, that's a sign of
supply coming into the market. It's a
sign of absorption. You have sellers
that are absorbing the aggressive
buying.
And it's similar on the opposite side in
terms of sell imbalances into green
candles.
Okay? So, here, we've got, you know, we
just made a low right here at 130.08,
kind of going sideways. Now, the
market's starting to get bid up, and
just before it pops up on this one
5-minute bar,
what led up to that is I see some strong
passive
buying here on the bid side, right?
Passive bids
are absorbing
that aggressive selling. That's what's
causing this sell imbalance, right? You
still have
strong selling, right? It's 689, but
I've also got strong buying, right? I
mean, it's not like they're selling into
nobody, they're selling into passive
buyers. So, what I have here is is the
market essentially getting bid up.
Right?
Buyers are stepping up to absorb
whatever aggressive selling. You know,
buyers are coming in saying, "Hey, you
know what? This low,
I want to support it." Right? And
they're bidding that market to absorb
all the aggressive selling that's going
on. And then right after that, you got
this nice stack buy imbalance. Now,
again, this is a bond this is a 5-minute
chart.
And
honestly, you don't always get a lot of
stack buy imbalances. Now, what are
stack buy imbalances or stack sell
imbalances? Three or more imbalances
neatly on top of each other, right?
That's what You got one stacked here,
right? One on top of each other for or
four price levels here, you got three.
Here, you got three. And generally, this
is, you know, it's sort of a a nice sign
of, you know, strong aggressive buying
or strong aggressive selling. You know,
it's aggressive selling if it's sell
imbalances. Obviously, it's aggressive
buying if it's buy imbalances. Now,
where it gets a little bit more
interesting, again, you on a 5-minute
chart, you don't really see a lot. And
remember, one imbalance by itself
probably doesn't mean much, right? Now,
there are times where, like I said, it's
a bit nuanced, and you got to sort of
take a step further than to say, "Oh,
there's an imbalance."
and trade it, right? You want to sort of
put the pieces together, do the
analysis, where is this buying imbalance
coming in, where is this selling
imbalance coming in, if it's just a
single one, right? If it's just a single
one in a bar, sometimes it has no
meaning, but if a market is going up
like here and I start seeing
um
selling imbalances on these green
candles, to me that's a sign of
buyers stepping up
essentially to support this market from
dropping further. Okay? Yes, I would
like to see aggressive buying coming in,
you know, with buying imbalances on a
move up off the low, but it's just as
important to see that strong bidding
coming in. Just as if a market is
starting to sell off, I like to see, you
know, supply coming in, leaving these
buying imbalances on the red candles.
And of course, I like to see
um further aggressive selling right
after that, just as I like to see um
aggressive buying coming in after I see
the supportive buying in terms of
the selling imbalances, okay? Now, this
is a 5-minute chart. Now, if you were to
go down to say a a 1-minute chart,
this is where it gets a little bit more
trickier because, you know, on markets,
especially like bonds, you know,
sometimes you don't get much price
movement
in a in a in a 1-minute bar, right? And
let's just go back to the day session
here
um this morning, you know, take it from
8:00 and, you know, a lot of these bars
is just trading, you know, two or three
price levels, sometimes four, but what
are you seeing? You're seeing, you know,
a bar has got a selling imbalance, next
bar has got one, next bar has got one,
next bar has got one, then you got one
bar with um you know, two. Problem is,
you know, if you're trading a market
that doesn't have much movement in bars,
um you know, it
it's I don't want to say it's
not as effective because then you got to
start stringing these bars together, but
often times you can get bars where you
got both buying and selling imbalances
in there.
Um but where it gets, you know, in my
opinion, a little bit more powerful is
if, you know, you you have these bars
that trade, you know, the bid and the
offer maybe one tick above, one tick
below, but you get the bar with the
stack selling imbalance or a stack
buying imbalance,
that's a pretty strong sign cuz it's
telling you over that 1-minute period
there was sustained aggressive selling,
right? Cuz remember, this is not a
range-based chart, this is a time-based
chart.
And for it to have continuous selling
for essentially 1 minute straight or,
you know, strong aggressive buying, you
know, in terms of a stack buying
imbalance for 1 whole minute being
sustained over that time period is
important, said cuz if this was just a
range-based chart, someone could sweep
right through, you know, three price
levels and you form another bar, you
know, instantly.
But when I see something like this on a
1-minute bar where I
am not really expecting very many buying
or selling stacked buying or stacked
selling imbalance, again, I'm looking at
stacked buying or stacked selling
imbalance looking for, you know, three
or more selling imbalances stacked
neatly on top of each other or three or
more stacked buying imbalances
stacked neatly on top of each other,
okay?
And, you know, a little bit later on the
way back up, we got a nice stacked
buying imbalance here.
Market kept going up, another stacked
buying imbalance right here.
And, you know, what's interesting is
because
when you have a stacked buying imbalance
or a stacked selling imbalance,
you know, it's telling you that there
was aggressive buying at those prices.
And often times the market can come back
to that level and I like to watch, you
know, what's going to happen when the
market comes back to that level. So, for
example, right, we had the stack selling
imbalance back here at 8:16, you know,
around the 130 20 to 22 area.
Market came back
and, you know, that is a resistance
level. Now, I do have a stack buying
imbalance going into resistance, if you
will. So, you know, um not sure if that
resistance is going to hold or we're
just going to just blow right through
it. In this case, we blew right through
it.
Um but now we got a support level coming
in, but you know, basically between 19
and, you know, 16. You know, market went
up from, you know, this level 23 all the
way up to whatever, 29, came right back
down to the support
and you can see how it's more or less
holding for, you know, from like 9:02
all the way over here to about 9:15 and
then it starts to slowly move back up.
So, you know,
stacked buying and stacked selling
imbalances do give you
opportunities to trade pullbacks
or bounces back up, you know, treat them
as support or resistance
um for when the market comes back there,
right? And we got
don't just blindly um
buy it or sell it, you know, I still
think you have to watch the order flow
cuz to be honest, you know, if I have
this resistance area and I've got very
strong aggressive buying coming in and,
you know, sort of on the back of that I
see some buying coming in, I'm already
thinking, "Oh, we can get easily get
past this area." Rather than just sort
of sitting back say, "Oh, you know what?
I got resistance, I'm just going to sell
it." But if I'm looking at this move up,
you know, I can see the selling
imbalance here, the selling imbalance
here, these two selling imbalances,
okay, but it's a red candle, kind of
expect that, but off this green candle
here, um you know, I've got some
aggressive buying on the way up and then
boom, right the bar that is going right
up towards it,
I got stack buying imbalance.
So, I could feel pretty confident that
this move is kind of strong. I've got
not only the aggressive buying, but I
got some supportive buying coming in as
well.
All right? So, then, you know,
on the way back, you know, we hit the
swing high, start coming off, you know,
maybe some supply coming in here. I know
I've got a support area here.
Um you know, and there's there's you
know, there's sellers in here. Honestly,
I'm not going to deny that there's
you've got sellers. I mean, you got
these buying imbalances, the 203, the
124, the 275, the 89.
And, you know, market is just sort of
hanging around this area here at 23.
It's it's not um really getting past it
very much, but at the same time, it's
not really selling it. So, what I I can
sort of surmise from this is that, you
know, I do have passive sellers up here
around this 23.
Okay? Can we move it back down into the
support here or not? Or we going to get
past it? We get past it, you got the
aggressive buying coming in and we come
up here to a new swing high at 29.
And then I start seeing signs of supply
coming into the market here, here, here,
right? And aggressive selling coming in.
And we come back down to our support
area
and we just we're holding this support,
right? It looks like, you know, there's
supply coming in, there's sellers, but
what's happened?
We still we're struggling to go lower.
At the same time that you have these
um
you have aggressive sellers, obviously,
but they're running into passive buyers.
That's why you have
selling imbalance pretty much in in
almost every
bar here. You know, I got selling
imbalance here, here, here, here, and
we're struggling to really get past that
area. So, I know that there's some
support, there's some supportive buying
in this market. So,
what do I have now?
Earlier, well, okay, let's start and let
me take a step back. Earlier, I had
strong aggressive buying here, right? A
stack buying imbalance.
Now, the market is coming back to that
area
and I'm seeing some strong passive
buying. Okay, well, I know I had some
strong aggressive buying earlier, now I
got strong passive buying. What do you
think that means
to the market? Well, it means there's
support here in this market
because
not only do you have, you know, passive
buying, but you also had that aggressive
buying earlier, which is what you like
to see.
And then you can see how the market is
sort of holding that area and then
eventually starts trading back up to
that 29, you know, sort of that swing
high from earlier.
So, that's one way to use
imbalances.
Again, there's different ways you could
could use them. I mean, the market's a
little bit nuanced, again, depending on
the market. Um
You know, some markets
you're going to see a bit more
imbalances. Um
and, you know, one thing, you know,
depending on the market you're trading,
you may want to use a minimum
uh volume for the imbalance.
My order flow software, you know, it
allows you to put in a minimum. I use
10, right? You can see minimum imbalance
volume of of 10 here. And what what that
means is there's got to be at least,
you know, 10 contracts on the imbalance,
meaning
even though I'm using 4 to 1, if I have
one against five, technically that's an
imbalance of over 4 to 1, but it doesn't
meet the minimum volume requirement.
Zero against four technically is an
imbalance, right? Nothing traded on the
bid, four traded on the offer,
but it doesn't meet the minimum volume
requirement. And, you know, and that
would matter, you know, in some of the
the thinner markets, um
you know, like, well, you know,
especially markets that trade,
you know, I want to say trade a a lot of
thin volumes, but, you know, sometimes
at price levels,
you don't get a lot of volume going
through because the market is a little
bit more volatile, right? It's it's
moving around and it can skip, you know,
certain price levels, right? Like in you
know, here this this is Russell, okay?
You can see a lot of zeros in here. So,
you know, one against eight is an
imbalance.
Um
You know, again, one versus eight, etc.
You know, zero against four, you know,
zero against four.
Um you know, and you you know, you get
the idea. It's not showing these as
imbalances because they don't meet the
minimum requirement, right? You you
don't want to be looking at a lot of
imbalances when it's just a market
that's not as liquid. So, by setting a
minimum volume of 10, in my opinion, you
know, it just helps to clean it up and
make it more understandable and
readable. If I were to
you know, change it to, you know, a a
lower number, let's just I'll just show
you.
Um change it from
10 to 4.
Click apply.
You know, there's going to be more
imbalances, right? And but it's not
about having more, it's about, you know,
understanding
really what's going on in the market.
You know, I'm not really concerned,
yeah, I've got imbalances here, zero
against four, zero against four, one
against four.
Um you know, one against four, but that
that's not really helping me, right? You
you want to be looking for imbalances on
solid volume. I don't say a lot of
volume, but solid volumes, okay?
So, again, you know, I I hope this
clears it up for you guys, but again,
you know, be sure to uh
you got any concerns or questions, just
put them in the comments, you know, I I
do get around to answering some of the
comments.
Um and sometimes, you know, I've been
making videos as replies to some of the
comments. So, again, be sure to like and
subscribe to the channel so that you'll
be notified whenever I post a new video.
And again, you know, thanks for
watching. Bye-bye.